here in New York an administrative judge
says the New York City police officer at
the center of the I can't breathe
confrontation that killed Eric garner
and set off a national conversation on
police use of force should be fired cell
phone video captured groaner pleading
that he couldn't breathe is off the
Daniel Pantaleo held him in a deadly
chokehold five years ago Pantaleo was
not charged in the criminal case
Garner's family and activists are
demanding Pantaleo permanent removal
from the police force Kenneth Craig is
here with more on this story Kenneth so
what does this really mean well good
morning to you Jeff this recommendation
to fire the officer is now headed to the
police commissioner who will ultimately
have the final say in the meantime the
officer has been suspended without pay
until a decision is made on his future
with the NYPD five years have passed
since the death of Eric Gardner an
unarmed black man whose dying words I
can't breathe
fueled nationwide protests against
police brutality on Friday a judge ruled
that NYPD officer Daniel Pantaleo should
be fired for using a deadly chokehold on
Gardner the ruling follows a grand jury
and federal prosecutors refusing to
indict Pantaleo on criminal and civil
charges before his suspension Friday the
officer had been stripped of his gun and
put on desk duty but continued to draw a
salary with his paid peeking at more
than 120 thousand dollars in 2017
protesters gathered after the
recommendation to voice their
disapproval of Mayor Bill de Blasio's
handling of the case Gardner's death
occurred during de Blasio's first year
in office until today the garner family
has been failed by this entire process
mayor de Blasio who initially showed
solidarity with the Gardner family
praised the judge's decision today we
finally saw a step towards justice and
accountability the head of the police
union condemned the judge's decision as
reckless how do we do our jobs if we
can't stop and say
sir you can't do that and they refused
the decision to fire Pantaleo is now up
to police commissioner James O'Neill
but for gardener's daughter emerald that
decision could not come soon enough
CCRB has made the recommendation
commissioner O'Neill fire Pantaleo the
officers attorney has two weeks to
respond before the police commissioner
makes the final decision that is
expected later this month and if he is
fired often the officers lawyer says
he'll appeal in state court Michelle